[Musique]
moi c'est marion kent j'ai 25 ans et je
suis professeur de danse danseuse mais
je suis aussi étudiante en doctorat
sylvain guineheux 26 ans graphiste
motion designer danseur chorégraphe ou
le
photographe tous ont fait du lindy hop
ou du soul jazz jane austen jazz
vernaculaire ça dépend comme on
l'appelle là il a pas un coup de l'homme
noir plane donc lénine diable c'est une
danse africaine américaine des années
1920 c'est une danse de couple elle a
été développée donc à la fin des années
1920 harlem aux états unis et ça se
danse sur le swing
[Musique]
bassin
le problème se pose de spécifiquement en
france mais pas que c'est qu'en fait en
france on genre lennon et donc on va
dire en cours le lead et la folle au
c'est à dire que on va genres et les
rôles de danse et on va appliquer du
coup voilà les verbes l'idée folle au ça
veut dire guider et suivre en anglais et
on va vraiment a signé un genre à une
action dans la danse donc par exemple on
va voir l'homme qui va guider et la
femme qui va suivre pour moi c'était
confortable en fait de
deux du côté de celle de l'id du coup
mais
après je crois que c'est comme
maintenant fait maintenant je tu ils
étaient au rôle soit à droite soit à
gauche après je suis majoritairement
quand même plus du côté leed mais je
prends vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
aussi à suivre en fait je crois que
j'aurais pu très bien apprendre à suivre
et ça m'aurait vraiment contente et
aussi
[Musique]
moi je n'ai pas choisi mon rôle de danse
quand j'ai commencé c'est à dire que
c'était à l'époque
on arrivait dans la salle de danse et
voilà il y avait des garçons des filles
et on a mis les garçons à gauche les
filles à droite on a formé des couples
hétérosexuels comme ça et donc on nous a
pas trop expliquer non plus les notions
dit déçu si je crois que j'ai pas trop
intégré ça au début c'est à dire que je
me suis pas posé plus de questions que
ça mais c'était aussi le début je rentre
à l'université donc je pense que c'était
le début aussi des réflexions un petit
peu aussi justement peu plus
philosophique un peu plus profond quand
même et intellectuel par rapport à ce
genre de trucs et l'année d'après ça a
commencé à me gêner en fait d'être
guidés et de sentir que l'autre pouvait
vraiment avoir un rapport de force est
de pouvoir sur moi et je suis en fait à
la réflexion après j'aurais préféré mois
guider et pas être guidé en fait c'est
gelé je les ai toujours dit et non par
la suite enfin moi pour mes recherches
j'ai découvert que à l'époque c'était ça
se passait pas comme ça quoi on est
vraiment dans une danse de la liberté
dans une danse de la transgression des
codes aussi est en fait c'est ça la
danse de couple on s'adapte à l'autre
c'est pas un monologue ainsi une
conversation si c'est un monologue moi
j'arrête de danse et j'ai pas envie
qu'on me parle pendant deux minutes à
chaque fois par mois ça rejoint vraiment
la question féministe aussi c'est j'ai
le choix de pouvoir suivre
un 100 % ou ne pas suivre à 100% donc je
choisis de ne jamais suivre à 100% et de
voir tout toujours mon grand pour soi
oui minimum je pense que dans la société
actuelle c'est plus accepter pour une
femme de passer dans le rôle de gauche
et de l'ide plutôt qu'un homme de passer
dans un rôle de suivi voilà parce que
c'est une société qui est très hétéro
normes et patriarcale encore donc on a
encore les valeurs de 1m sa guide ça
suit pas guider et dominer ou suivre
seul sfr pour moi comme dans la dans la
danse comme dans la vie privée je ça
marche pas avec moi
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]